I have some video and audio for you today.
That is truly the height of absurdity when
you talk about unelected people in positions
of power merely because they are related to
someone.
Of course, our minds immediately should go.
When I say that to Ivana Trump and her husband,
Jared Kushner, Donald Trump's son in law,
Jared Kushner, was interviewed by Time magazine
earlier this week, and he was asked, is it
possible, possible that the November election
could be postponed because of Corona virus?
Now, before I play the audio for you, the
question is fraught.
The question is fraught because it's not really
up to the Trump administration.
You'd have to move heaven and earth to do
it, but you could ask 50 states individually
to postpone their elections.
And there's a question as to whether all states
would even be able to do it.
But even if you managed to do that, you could
really only delay the November election a
few weeks, because in December, the electors
have to certify that election, unless you
can actually get well, would likely need to
be a constitutional change or maybe a Supreme
Court decision.
It would be insanely difficult to actually
postpone the November election.
It's also a fraught question because Jared
Kushner should have no involvement or opinion
about this at all.
He's just Trump's son in law.
He's been made an advisor, which is horrifying,
but OK.
Jared Kushner is asked about this.
Now, what I want to think about here is whether
this has been blown out of proportion, because
there have been a lot of apoplectic headlines
saying Jared Kushner is laying the groundwork
to postpone the presidential election or trying
to postpone the presidential election.
I don't know that that's the case necessarily
looking at the clip.
Let's take a look at it.
Is there any scenario, including a second
outbreak in the fall where the elections may
past November 3rd?
That's too far in the future to tell.
Nothing that I'm aware of now.
But again, our focus right now is just getting
the.
Elections will happen on November 3rd.
It's not my decision to make side.
I'm not sure I can commit one way or the other.
But right now, that's the plan.
And again, hopefully by the time we get to
September, October, November, we've done enough
work with testing and with and with all the
different things we're trying to do.
So Jared says the plan is for November 3rd.
I can't commit to it, but it's not his position
to commit.
He has no power in when the election is held.
Even Trump essentially has no power and when
the election is held.
So I actually do believe this was a little
bit blown out of proportion.
There's another idea which is OK.
Jared can't do anything about it, but that's
why Jared said it.
It's a trial balloon to gage reaction to it.
If people go absolutely crazy.
In the end, Jared has no say or involvement
in this.
So it's no big deal.
On the other hand, if Jared Kushner were to
say something and the reaction to it is positive
or not that negative, then this could be actually
sort of a trial balloon.
I just don't buy it.
I think what happened here is that Jared Kushner's
wording is very clumsy.
And what we're mostly reacting to is the fact
that Jared Kushner shouldn't be involved at
all in anything that's going on.
He shouldn't be answering questions about
when the election is going to be held.
He should be barred by nepotism laws from
even being involved with this administration.
Now, don't get me wrong, Donald Trump may
well be thinking of trying to move the election.
He may end up trying to move the election.
I just don't think Jared Kushner's comments
are the smoking gun.
And I also don't believe Trump would succeed
in doing it now, in any case.
This blew up and Jared Kushner ended up having
to put out a comment clarifying what he said.
And he said, quote, I have not been involved
in nor am I aware of any discussions about
trying to change the date of the presidential
election.
So for me, the story is not Jared Kushner
is floating, moving the election.
To me, the story is why are people talking
to Jared Kushner?
Why is Jared Kushner involved in things he
knows nothing about?
Jared Kushner has no authority.
Trump doesn't even have the legal authority
to move the election.
Are they trying to?
Are they likely the Trump administration?
Are they likely to try to do everything they
can to maintain power?
Of course, voter suppression, disinformation,
propaganda, lying about their handling of
Corona virus, lying about the state of the
economy, lying about Joe Biden, they're going
to do what we would colloquially call trying
to rig the election in their favor.
But it's not going to be Jared Kushner changing
election day.
Now, what can we do?
Number one, don't fall for the propaganda.
Number two, push states to adopt, vote by
mail.
Number three, get people registered.
Number four, obviously, make sure that you
vote.
One less thing on postponing the election,
which I think is important.
That and it should reduce the hysteria a little
bit.
If the election is postponed.
Imagine they succeed.
Right.
I don't see the path through it, but imagine
they succeed.
And there is no new president to inaugurate
in January of 2021.
I'm just thinking out loud here, the speaker
of the House becomes the president.
Now, right now, that's Nancy Pelosi.
Democratic Congresswoman Nancy Pelosi.
I believe Trump will do anything that he can
to prevent Nancy Pelosi from becoming president
of the United States.
Now, if you really want to get in the weeds,
you could have a situation where there's no
election in November.
Imagine I don't think it's good.
But imagine there's no election in November.
And because the election is postponed, you
don't even have enough Congress people to
have them in D.C. with a quorum to make.
Nancy Pelosi, the president in that case,
is the next person in line becomes the next
person in line to be president would be the
Senate president.
Pro temp right now.
That's Chuck Grassley.
This obviously gets very dicey in that Republicans
would likely in that scenario try to prevent
it from going to Nancy Pelosi.
Skip over her and go to Grassley.
I'm merely going through the motions here.
I don't believe this would happen.
But there is a scenario where the outcome
of Trump's postponing of the election makes
Nancy Pelosi the president, until an election
is held.
There's no way Trump is going to take any
action that would make
that likely.